– Für das Fahrrad.
– Du hast deinen Lohn bekommen.
– Mhm. Und ein sehr gutes
Praktikumszeugnis.
– Wow. Glückwunsch!
Gut gemacht!
– Danke.
Ich habe mir überlegt,
ich möchte weiter beim Film arbeiten.
– Okay.
– Ich könnte Schauspieler werden.
Es gibt ziemlich gute
Schauspielschulen hier in Deutschland.
– Stopp mal!
Hast du dir das gut überlegt?
– Na ja, es …
es macht mir Spaß.
– Ich habe einen Freund,
der Schauspieler ist.
Er ist sogar ziemlich berühmt
und hat für eine Rolle mal
einen Filmpreis gewonnen.
– Wow, echt?
– Ja. Und seit einem Jahr
hat er keine Aufträge mehr.
– Was?
– Die meisten Schauspieler
verdienen so wenig Geld,
dass sie mehrere Jobs machen müssen.
Ich unterstütze dich, Nico.
Wenn es das ist, was du willst, dann ...
kriegen wir das hin.
Aber ist es das, was du willst?